I'm here with Dr Markie Blumer, who used to be my professor for Human Sexuality
when I was in my undergraduate. And, I was also her teaching assistant for a
semester. Can you tell us a little bit about your background? I am a licenced
marriage and family therapist, I am also a licenced mental health counselor.
I'm, I'm an approved supervisor with the American Association for Marriage and
Family Therapy. I began teaching about human sexuality in 1998 as an assistant
at the Northern Arizona University. Starting in the fall 2013, I will be an
associate professor at the University of Wisconsin at the stout location. And
that'll be in the human development family studies program and marriage and
family therapy program. For the last four years, I've been an assistant
professor at the University of Nevada Las Vegas. And my PhD is in human
development and family studies with an emphasis in marriage and family therapy
from Iowa State University.
>> So what are the stages of the human sexual response? Yeah, great question,
actually that depends on who stages we're talking about. So Helen Singer Kaplan
came up with a three phase cycle of the human sexual response. Which included
the desire phase, an arousal phase and then ended with an orgasm phase. Masters
and Johnsons came up with a four stage model. So a little bit different than
Kaplan's model. And their four stage model included an excitement phase, a
plateau phase, an orgasm phase and a resolution phase. So really the biggest
difference was the resolution phase. In other words, they though that there
were something that happened after people reach a plateau or a peek of
excitement through orgasm. And that was kind of this refractory period that
people go through. Where their bodies go back to more of a normative state
before arousal occurred. Both of these models are great from a western point of
view. there's, there's nothing wrong with these models. They, they match human
physiology in a pretty normative way. What's problematic about them however is
not everybody Is situated to understand sexuality and sexual response cycles
from a western point of view. In eastern cultures, there are kind of different
ways of conceptualizing sexuality which would be through more like tantric
practices. Which doesn't really have this rigid here are the phases of sexual
response cycle that you must complete in order for it to be successful. So,
really those practices are more like, you might be aroused and then you might
kind of take a break and then you might become aroused again. and then you
might engage in sexual activity with each other. But rather than having an
orgasm, be say the goal for one person, it might just be a goal for one of the
other people involved. One person might just might take their time and the
other person might be orgasming multiple times. And maybe one partner never
orgasms and, and that would be considered a great sexual encounter. So really
it just depends on where you are on the globe. Like I said here in Western
Culture we have kind of these two ways of thinking about sex.